bonjour nicolas ravi de vous retrouver
dans la matinale de rtl france alors
barbara pompili s'est invitée hier soir
dans l'émission de télé-réalité top chef
à quelques mois de la présidentielle
qu'est ce qu'on a au menu ce matin et
moi je suis prête un homme imparfait
magali pouvoir écouter cette édition on
va se régaler ce matin oui car il a
fallu à ressorts s'imposer la séquence
politique de barbara pompidou et les
casseroles magique dans un grand show
écolo alors que l'exécutif vous l'avez
dit ne sais pas quelle sauce il va être
mangé s'il s'avérait qu'un des membres
du gouvernement et participer à un de
ces dîners et bien barbara pompili elle
était hier soir dans l'émission top chef
alors pour celles et ceux qui ne
connaissent pas cette émission c'est le
koh lanta de la cuisine la pêche la
cueillette et le totem d'immunité en
moins et je vous vois venir chers
téléspectateurs
alors je vous le dit tout de go non ce
n'était pas pour participer à une bombe
au chat suite aux révélations de
confrères de m6 qui ont jeté un gros
pavé dans la soutient louis seize noms
barbares pompiers étaient sur top chef
pour parler d'écologie est absolument
rien d'autre
l'entourage de la ministre a bien pris
soin de préciser qu'il est important de
faire de l'écologie grand public et pour
cette émission enregistrée en novembre
dernier à l'hôtel de roquelaure où
installer le ministère de la transition
écologique
il a été imposé un protocole sanitaires
strictes valider directement par le
cabinet d'olivier ferrand le pizzaïolo
en chef de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
d'abord à pompe il y était donc là pour
s'assurer au côté d'un chef étoilé que
les assiettes incarné l'engagement pour
la survie de la planète c'est tellement
magnifique on aimerait croire à une
parodie recyclées mais non magali je
prends parce que c'est une bonne chose
plutôt de sensibiliser les français à
l'écologie non oui effectivement mais là
vous savez c'est comme lorsque nos
enfants ne veut pas manger d'un
médicament
la meilleure façon de lui faire avaler
c'est de le mélanger dans la curée sous
deux gros morceaux de beurre bio et ça
devienne de suite beaucoup plus facile
bulls avaient alors pourquoi pourquoi
barbara pompili et estelle sur top chef
hier soir toute la question est là
alors parce que les discours finalement
politiques sont devenus tellement
répulsifs et allergènes pour les
français que nos chers communicants des
grandes gueules
ministériels parce qu'ils passeront
mieux entre deux bouchées de mozzarella
nappé d'une crème de homard en prime
time pour être vraiment utile un fait
barbara pompiers elle devrait plutôt se
dégager du temps pour relire et bosser
sur ces affreux traité de libre échange
signés par l'union européenne vous le
savez auxquelles la france doit se plier
et se soumettre citons en quelques uns
même si les mots sont barbares c'est à
gesta mercosur en plus des accords
signés avec le japon le vietnam la corée
du sud la liste qui est longue et non
recyclables donc finalement on préfère
donc écologiser le bon peuple dans des
émissions de divertissement en
interdisant le plastique à usage unique
sur un plateau de télévision et nous
faire la leçon sur le gaspillage
alimentaire soupoudrée de gestes
barrières et de tests pcr maintenant
c'est là vraiment connu par contre par
contre ça ne dérange pas le moins du
monde
barbara pompili et le gouvernement de ne
rien faire contre la pollution à grande
échelle
autour de la planète avait des
supertankers les dégazages des
directions de fioul car ces traités de
libre échange d'un favorise la
production intensive encourage la
déforestation les émissions de gaz des
marées noires ainsi ainsi qu'une
concurrence déloyale au détriment de
notre économie et notamment pour nos
agriculteurs au bord de l'explosion
en réalité la doxa néolibérale la
mondialisation des passes des politiques
et contre la démocratie ou l'écrasent
comme de la vulgaire purée elle est donc
pour vous il ya tous les ingrédients
d'une mauvaise stratégie je comprends
basser des responsables politiques la
télévision c'est une très vieille
histoire d'amour on le sait un mieux
aujourd'hui elle est le symptôme d'une
élite politique en déroute qui
délaissent les médias traditionnels pour
les prime time du spectacle on prépare
donc des plats de communication bien
crémeux et plein d'huile sur l' ensemble
de sujets importants qui me pousse à
l'indigestion
cela signifie quoi et bien ce lundi
plusieurs choses
- vous avez de marge manoeuvre - vous
avez des manettes - vous d'essayer pour
vous même plus forcément vous êtes
soumis à une mondialisation qui détruit
la france et qui ainsi des pouvoirs en
place à la vendre à la découpe
alors automatiquement vous communiants
beaucoup milk et parlons encore plus et
vous multipliez les éléments de langues
âge pour masquer votre impuissance a
décidé à agir emballé c'est pesé
barbara pompili se justifier récemment
que la télévision je suis touché tous
les foyers il a ajouté je cite encore
les émissions comme top chef permettent
de se détendre tout en faisant passer un
certain nombre de messages qui sont
parfois mieux entendu que sur d'autres
supports
je ne sais pas vous magali mais moi ça
me fait un peu penser au temps de
cerveau humain disponible vendu à une
célèbre marque de soda il ya quelques
années
en conclusion finalement mais ce que
touchent réellement notre classe
politique avec cette communication c'est
le fond de la casserole de la capacité
politique à diriger un pays est à
refaire nation car ils ne sont plus que
l'économie d'une arrière cuisines de
bruxelles sans tablier car les grands
chefs eux ne sont pas en france parce
que par les politiques dans une émission
de télé réalité avait découvert en
plastique recyclable et du quinoa est
coresponsable de tanzanie n'empechera
pas qu'une grande partie des français
feront bientôt leur cuisine avec tout ce
qui leur est c'est-à-dire de l'eau
municipale est le propre de la cuisine
politique et de ramollir les esprits
vider le portefeuille sans remplir
l'estomac sur ce bon appétit bon appétit
nicolas j'aurais quand même une petite
réaction si vous le voulez bien parce
que l'intervention de barbara compilé à
top chef est un peu con concomitant avec
ce qui se passe avec les dîners mondains
dont qu'en pensez vous
perquisition aujourd'hui un grand chef
notamment bien entendu vous savez c'est
je le disais souvent c'est souvent là la
france est déplorable un qui regarde
finalement là les élites kérosène chers
amis chers qui ce qui se délestent
finalement des règles absolues qui
bafoue les règles de l'état et même si
certains je suis très embêté parce que
certains éditorialistes depuis quelques
jours finalement nous disent que c'est
le propre des pesées révélation s'assure
de la délation et je crois que j'avais
misé mauvaise parce que concrètement ça
met en exergue une france des 11% vous
le savez magali c'est 1% ceux qui sont
au dessus parce qu'ils ont les moyens
c'est cette élite finalement kérosène
j'aime beaucoup cette expression et
c'est des gens qui ne s'embarrasse de
rien qui bafouent les lois de la
république et qui vivent dans un monde
déconnecté ce sont des gens hors sol qui
n'ont que faire que le pauvre français
lui arras et d'attestations de mesures
de pv d'amande et fait qu'une série de
choses finalement continue à piquer les
gestes barrière continue à être confiné
parce que c'est un confinement
donc voyez c'est cette fracture c'est
cette sédition finalement d'une certaine
partie des élites et je crois que c'est
quand même assez caractéristique de ce
que nous vivons aujourd'hui c'est cette
france qui est coupée en plusieurs mains
et à plusieurs morceaux et finalement on
se rend compte que ça met en exergue
cette crise sanitaire elle a mis en
exergue une séduction de gens qui ne
veulent absolument pas faire comme les
autres parce qu'ils ont de l'argent et
sa selle deviennent extrêmement
problématique merci beaucoup nicolas
merci en tout cas pour votre édito ce
matin dans la matinale d arte france et
bon appétit à vous